اعداد يعني القتلى ارتفع عائله 83 قتيل في
هذه المناطق لوحدها معظمهم في الريف
الشرقي
والغربي بمدينه تحديدا في بلدات اعزاز
وجنديرس
لا يزال عدد كبير من الناس تحت الانقاض
فيما لا تزال يعني منظمه الدفاع المدني
والاهالي يحاولون انتشال بعض الاحياء من
تحت الانقاض وايضا انتشال الجسس ونقلهم
الى المشافي القريبه وتحديدا الى مشفى
عفرين العسكري الذي وصله حتى الان اكثر من
32 جثه
لمدنيين قضوا تحت في هذا الزلزال محمد في
عموم سوريا العدد اقترب عدد القتلى اقتربا
من 200 قتيل وحوالي الالف
الاصابه او لا فقط فقط دعنا نجدد
المعلومات قليلا جمعه انت الرقم الذي
ذكرته في المناطق الخاضعه لسيطره الفصائل
السوريه المواليه لتركيا بلغ عدد القتلى
83 قتيلا كانت السلطات الصحيه السوريه
تحدثت ان عدد القتلى في المناطق تحت سيطره
النظام وصل الى
237 وبالتالي ربما المجموع يقترب من 320
قتيل ما بين المناطق التي سيطر عليها
النظام والمناطق التي تسيطر عليها الفصائل
السوريه المواليه لتركيا سؤال مهم جدا
ايضا بما ان هذه المناطق تحت السيطره
القوات التركيه هل تم
ايصال اي دعم او اي مساعدات من الاراضي
التركيه لتلك المناطق المتضرره
محمد يعني حتى الان المشافي المحليه او
العيادات الصغيره في القرى والاقضيه هي
التي تتولى مهمه استقبال الناجين من
الزلزال ومعالجتهم بينما الحالات الاكثر
صعوبه والتعقيدا يتم توجيها الى مشاكل في
مدينه ادلب ومشتاق العسكري في مدينه
عفرين كون كون يعني رئيس حلب هو الاكثر
تضررا لكن حتى الان يعني لم يكن هناك نقل
للجرحى او المصابين الى الى المستشفيات
التركيه